marine c'est le peuple c'est la
candidate du peuple la jeunesse à
l'arête marine lebel est la meilleur
futur président
[Applaudissements]
je veut miser sur la jeunesse cette
belle jeunesse de france
[Applaudissements]
installez les chaises on a misé affiches
on a été donné dès drapeaux au même
moment le meeting avait commencé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
au mas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà on va coller un panneau juste à
côté de chez moi d'ailleurs
on va mettre deux affiches de marine
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
et ça m'a tout de suite donné envie de
voter pour marine tout simplement parce
qu'elle était
simple et l aller vers les gens c'est à
dire qu elle étai
percutante moi c'est ce que j'aimais
chez elle elle s'intéressa à tous les
français déjà depuis 2012
c'est un terme qui a été prononcée par
des gens qui sont satisfaits aujourd'hui
du système mais c'est tout à leur
honneur aujourd'hui on a bien vu ce que
le système était capable de faire
pendant cinq ans avec emmanuel macron
donc marine le pen est tout sauf
l'extrême droite et on trouvera aussi
pendant ces cinq prochaines années
bonjour madame
bachelot
en a la chance au rassemblement national
d'être un parti qui fait confiance aux
jeunes
moi ça m'a permis d'être candidat aux
des mes 18 ans d'ailleurs aux
municipales après au départemental et à
bhl et puis en fait on sent utile aussi
quand militer c'est ça qui est important
commencé à militer du coup tassetto
après les attentats du 13 novembre ce
que j'ai considéré que c'était pas
possible que dans ce pays on est plutôt
en trente personnes qui soient
assassinés dans les rues de paris et
donc quand on considère que ça peut pas
arriver que c'est pas normal et qu'on
voit autour de nous les problèmes que ce
soit la désindustrialisation les
problèmes d'argent des gens ou des fois
la misère dans lequel y vivre et on dit
qu'il faut changer les choses
[Musique]
en
fait c'est ce qu'on dit aux gens on fera
peut-être pas tout ce que vous voulez
moment fera des choses on mettra fin à
la casse sociale on défendra le pouvoir
d'achat on assurera la sécurité des
français les a je pense qu'on fait qu'on
soit de gauche qu'on soit de droite tout
le monde peut s'y retrouver
[Musique]
marine a toutes ses chances de
l'emporter donc nous on est là pour
convaincre les derniers et pour
mobiliser surtout pour que les gens
donnent donne leur chance à marine donne
sa chance à marine ce dimanche